just as i started to wonder what the
hell are we going to talk about
here pftpm 5 eastern on peacock jj watt
post the picture of himself in an
arizona cardinals
t-shirt jj watts 17 days into his 33-day
head start on free agency
he has a new team i can't tell if that's
real or if that's photoshopped
either way cardinals i did a double take
when i saw it i thought he was messing
with us in some way he wasn't
he has side with the cardinals shireen
good afternoon and what was your first
reaction when you saw that tweet
uh surprise mike surprised for
what they're paying him and surprised
that it was the arizona cardinals i mean
when we went on with with miles and did
our picks right we picked nine teams the
cardinals were not among those nine
teams that we picked
so total surprise out of the blue that
the the cardinals of the team but i
think j.j watt for doing something today
because i always laugh when people ask
me what do you do in the off season
well there's something every single day
it seems
oh it is funny that people think we just
shut it down
the day after the super bowl and do
nothing
until training camps open and or the
regular season begins because a lot of
people don't pay attention to football
until the games are on tv but yeah
there's always something even on a day
when we think there's going to be
nothing
there inevitably will be something and
it is jj watt
member of the cardinals multiple reports
are that it's a two-year 31 million
dollar deal that's 15.5 million per year
23 million guaranteed now we've learned
over time that when the reports
say guaranteed and not fully guaranteed
it's not fully guaranteed
it's guaranteed for injury how much is
fully guaranteed at signing
that's the key but for a guy like jj
watt it helps to have that injury
guarantee because
you can almost guarantee he's going to
be injured and he'd have protection
against any compensation next year that
otherwise would be
non-guaranteed but just like any of
these other deals shireen i want to see
what the details are signing bonus full
guarantee at signing
cash flow this year cash flow next year
i mean
in theory it could be backloaded
and i know there are rules on how much
you can dump into the second year
but for cap purposes since it's going to
be low this year
they could have pushed as much as
possible into next year and maybe a lot
of it isn't
guaranteed next year so we'll wait and
see but with only a two year deal
it's hard to hide a whole lot of fluff
in the contract
two years 31 million if he plays for
them for two years he's going to get the
31. the question is is it one year
that he's with the cardinals or is it
two
yeah absolutely mike and the devil is
always in the details and agents
always tend to inflate these numbers as
we know every agent does it it's great
when it first comes out
because people forget all they see is
the two years 31 million
they forget the rest when you go back
and you're right well it really means
this this and this
people don't remember that they just
remember the two years 31 million we go
back and write other stories it's two
years 31 million
no matter what the real final numbers
say mike and so you know it will be
interesting to see
what this entails the cardinals how long
he plays the cardinals but they have
become
the houston west i guess texans west
whatever you want to call it because
we're seeing an influx of players from
texas headed that way conor murray of
course didn't play for the texans but he
is from texas and now they have de'andre
hopkins
and jj watt two of the best players in
texas history frankly mike
that the thing that that fascinates me
is the possibility however slim it may
be
but something that dawned on me after i
considered deandre hopkins with the
cardinals j.j what with the cardinals
desean watson wants out of the texans
could the cardinals become intrigued by
the possibility of a flip-flop
kyle murray for deshawn watson reminds
me a lot of the old
dan pastorini for kenny stabler trade
back from
our childhood and i remember how stunned
i was when that happened straight up
quarterback for quarterback i i think
the chances of it happening are
ridiculously
small but it's hard not to at least
think about it because it would put
kylie murray back in texas
and it would put desean watson back with
deandre hopkins and j.j watt and it
would give him what he wants
his ticket out of houston now kyler
murray may not want to be a texan
that's that's a different issue
altogether but uh
it's hard not to at least think about
that when you consider that hopkins got
what he wanted
his reunion with j.j watt and we have
kyler murray
he tweeted something today let's see
what it is
i haven't seen it yet full transparency
and here it is
here it is here it comes i mean it this
time
here it is kyler murray with jj watt
uh when kyler murray was a senior in
high school that's also
carl anthony towns with j.j watt jj
looking a little large there i don't
know maybe it's just a bad camera angle
but
he is large he just looks a little
larger right there kyler murray
not large next to j.j watt or or next to
me
as the case may be yeah sharing but uh
yeah
they are teammates they are teammates at
least for now but in this crazy upside
down
off season i will rule out nothing
not a thing and the the chances of kyler
murray and cliff kingsbury separating
are very very very very very very slim
but it's fun to think about
desean watson to the cardinals and kyler
murray to the texans uh because
really as the texans go when you're
talking about a straight up quarterback
for quarterback deal
and and replacing what you have with
another guy
who is a rare talent there aren't many
guys out there
that would that would suit that and
i think tyler murray would i think the
cardinals would have to throw in
something else they don't have david
johnson anymore to throw in
and jokingly i think there's got to be
somebody else
if they have this contract they want to
get rid of yeah right
exactly but whoever it is mike
it would save face for the texans right
texas fans are going to be mad
if they trade desean watson there's no
question about that they're going to be
furious and they're going to be furious
with jack easterbeak
but if you brought in a player like
connor murray who grew up in texas
who played at texas a m briefly before
going to oklahoma who has
ties deep ties to state of texas the
plenty of texas fans would would be
thrilled with this
if kyler was thrilled with going to
houston but texas fans i i just think it
would really it really makes sense if
you're going to trade deshaun watson
and it's obvious to everyone except the
texans that they're going to have to do
that
this totally makes perfect sense and it
upgrades the cardinals too because
we all think deshaun watson has done
more so far in his career
than kyler murray has right so i think
it would be an upgrade
for the cardinals so it does make sense
i don't think it ever happens
but it does make perfect sense to me
that that that would be a trade that
would work out for both teams
we don't see many trades that work out
for both teams we saw the diggs trade
last year worked out for minnesota
obviously
with the draft pick they used on justin
jefferson and it worked out for the
bills because diggs had a great year for
the bill so
not many of these do that would be one i
could see working out for both teams
mike
yeah the wild card though would be kyler
murray does he want to do it and
even though he doesn't have a no trade
clause you you
you don't want a franchise quarterback
who doesn't want to be with the
franchise and also
he could always say see you later i'm
going to play baseball
that would be the other risk that the
texans would have to assume
now they could collect some money back
from kylo murray he's got two years of
signing bonus
that to date he has not yet earned
but but even then you're right to check
if you're getting some big signing bonus
to go play for the a's or whoever would
hold his
rights right now in baseball remember he
was a top 10 draft pick in the mlb draft
and that that leverage always exists
that he can say
see you later to football and you know
look at it this way he'd go to the
texans for two years
and then just leave at that point and
owe them nothing if he decides to go
play baseball because there would be no
repayment obligation in his fifth year
options so
again i it's just something i thought of
and it does make sense for the texans
and you could argue it makes sense for
the cardinals
and the only person it may not make
sense for is kyle murray and it's fairly
important
that it would make sense for kyler
murray uh deandre
hopkins has to be happy we first had the
possibility of j.j watt
on the cardinals radar screen thanks to
the andre hopkins tweet which was a
perfect photoshop in the cardinals
uniform
complete with the larry wilson number
eight
tribute on the jersey so hopkins ahead
of his time
on this and hopkins gets his wish
a reunion with jj watt that was very
well done that was right out of the
gates that was day
one that is some excellent photoshop
work i did a double take because it kind
of looks like
a texan's dark blue like really dark i
was like what is that and then i saw the
cardinals logo on hopkins jersey i saw
the eight ball
on the the left shoulder of what it's
like holy crap they did some sort of a
photoshop
with him in cardinals gear and uh well
done there and
and well done cardinals you got jj watt
here's the other thing i'd like to know
shireen
what was the next best offer
for j.j watt was there someone else
offering two years 30
was it two years 25 i how
how were the cardinals positioned with
another team and were they ultimately
bidding against themselves
to pay that kind of money to get jj walk
because i feel like instead of him
chasing
a potential championship he chased the
almighty dollar
which is perfectly fine got no problem
with it i'm a capitalist but it feels
more like
instead of saying i'm going to a place
where i think the deck is stacked in my
favor to get a ring
i'm going to a place where i'm going to
get some coin instead
no question about it mike i'm if you're
going to go to a contender right you're
going to go to tampa you're going to go
to kansas city
i mean there's green bay there's
multiple places that i would have picked
over the cardinals not that they're not
going to be in contention because i
think they have a pretty good roster but
they just
haven't shown that that they're ready to
take that next step i mean they went
eight and eight and didn't even make the
postseason this year so there were other
places
that j.j white could have gone that that
perhaps could have gotten him to a super
bowl
quicker than the cardinals and it is
obvious that he
probably went for the money mike and i
will be curious like you
how many teams got in on this how many
teams were
truly offering good money to jj watt
perhaps this was the only offer of big
money that he had and
and so he took it and that's fine but
you know to say you're going to
contender i'm not sure that quite worked
out like that now he did say he wanted
to go to a place that had a quarterback
so it's obvious he has a belief in kyle
murray like a lot of people do he did
make his first pro bowl this year
so but kyler's got to prove it right
he's got to prove it in the postseason
which he hasn't
done yet so we'll see how that works out
but um
i i would have picked pittsburgh perhaps
joining his brothers i know the cap
problems they have tennessee made sense
to me
because mike frable's there this just
was not even on my radar of teams that i
would have seen
jj white going to i thought buffalo
about buffalo i thought cleveland
buffalo perhaps
both of them are more viable contenders
when you consider the division
rams beefing up with matthew stafford
seahawks unless they trade russell
wilson
49ers if they're healthy the cardinals
can end up in fourth place
they could be an improved team and be in
fourth place
in their own division and you know now
that there are three wild card teams it
is possible that one of these divisions
could send all four teams to the
playoffs and
if any division would do it it would be
the nfc west but
but i i just think this is more about
understanding there's only so much you
can control
there's only so much of a difference one
guy can make so
since i can't force
the road to the super bowl through my
own backyard
i can't control it as one human being on
a football team
let's just go get paid with a team that
we think is reasonably
in contention and if it works out it
works out if it doesn't
i got a lot of money for the physical
risks and sacrifices that i take every
time i step onto that field and we know
with jj watt that's a significant thing
now in the photoshop
that we had of jj watt with deandre
hopkins he was wearing
number 99 that may be a problem as
pointed out by darren urban
of the cardinals and others 99 is
retired
by the arizona cardinals marshall
goldberg
elkins west virginia native which i did
not know
until right before the play and there he
is marshall goldberg
skinnier than me running the football no
face mask days with the chicago
cardinals this is why
frankly shireen i'm not a big fan of the
retired jerseys
because you will eventually get to a
point where people will be like
who that's i was like who i sorry i'm
not
the football historian that chris sims
is but i bet he doesn't know who
marshall goldberg is either
and hell i live an hour from elkins i
should know that i said you know maybe
i've driven to elkins and there's a big
sign that says home of marshall goldberg
and just never registered that he was an
nfl player
who has a number retired by the chicago
cardinals now the arizona cardinals but
you know at some point you run out of
numbers you can retire it's always
something that's kind of made me nervous
in an ocd kind of way
like at what point do you have to say
remember that whole thing with retired
numbers
we just have to we have to not do that
and in this case
jj watson's gonna have to pick a
different number
i love what the cowboys do they don't
retire numbers so 12 hasn't been
worn since roger stahlbach but if you
had a quarterback coming in like a
trevor lawrence and he has to wear 12. i
bet the cowboys would do it
88 has become a very historical number
for the cowboys
you know we've seen dez and bob and
michael irvin and and all these guys
wear 88
and it's become a traditional number
drew pearson just got went into the hall
of fame with 88
i like that kind of thing mike where you
kind of hand down those great numbers
and you only do it to great players
because
we want to see jj watt right in a 99
jersey
is there any possible way they can wave
this and say
we're going to let him play in 99 can
you un-retire a number
i don't know if it's ever been done
before oh it has been
peyton manning when he went to denver he
talked that's right
frank trapuca and and i i
i'm just going to say it because i
didn't like it then and the passage of
time does not make me like it anymore i
don't like the idea that peyton manning
puts the muscle
verbally on frank torpuca because what's
frank trapuca gonna say
no you put him in a tough spot you ask
him if you can wear his number he's not
gonna say
ah you know what they retired my not you
come off as petty
if you say well you know what it is my
number and i'm not gonna let you wear it
now
one of these days i'd love to see a
colts player number 18
ask peyton manning hey can i wear your
number and see what peyton manning would
do
i just don't like that and i didn't like
it then i don't like it now
and i don't like the idea and i hope it
doesn't happen that the cardinals ask
the family of marshall goldberg
hey do you mind if this guy wears your
number 99 because
you're in a position where you come off
as
perceived as a jerk if you say no
and tom brady was rather ready to change
numbers right if chris godwin didn't
give him the number he was ready to
change numbers i mean if tom brady can
do it anybody can do it right and he
ended up not having to do it obviously
because chris godwin gave up the number
but hey you know it it's been done where
guys have played one number with one
team and a different number with a
different team and
he's going to sell a lot of jerseys
whatever that number is mike the
cardinals are going to see a lot of
those jerseys in the stands next year
99 or not 99 no matter what it is j.j
watt jerseys will be in the stands in
arizona next year
and i understand the psychology of it
but it is
a dehumanizing digit that is placed onto
your jersey
that that just helps the officials
distinguish
one gladiator from the other and and i
guess
taking control and saying this is my
number is a way to inject your own
humanity into this dehumanizing effort
of placing numbers on people
i get that but at a certain point you
got to say it doesn't matter
i'm still the same player whatever
number i wear is the number i wear and i
just think that
hey he had to go into this eyes wide
open
and and and for all hey for all we know
part of the negotiation was the
cardinals are going to take it on
themselves
to get marshall goldberg's family to let
jj what we're number 99
i just i i hope i hope
that i'm not a fan of retiring numbers
but i hope
that the retirement of marshall
goldberg's number is respected shireen
yeah absolutely mike and you know pick
another number jj
and you'll be known for 99 in houston in
a different number
in arizona i do have a question here
mike because hassan reddick probably
leaves now right in free agency and
he wanted to stay there and he had 12
and a half sacks of course five of them
came in one game do you think
j.j watt is a significant upgrade on
hassan reddick i have
wrestled with this all day now he's
going to be a better leader
i get that veteran leadership everything
he brings to the team
but is he at this point his career
better pass rusher than hassan reddick
well i think he's more consistent and he
is a better leader
he's what they need i think to coalesce
their defense who's the guy
when you think of the cardinals defense
who's the guy that's the heart and soul
do they have a guy who's the heart and
soul of the defense they really don't
now they suddenly have a heart attack i
mean chandler jones yeah he's the best
player
but is he the heart and soul is he the
guy that pulls it all together i feel
like they haven't had a guy that pulls
it all together
since tyron matthew and even with him he
was kind of a step behind patrick
peterson
i think this makes it more and more
clear that patrick peterson's going to
be gone
i just think they want a sheriff for
their defense
a guy who brings it all together a guy
who's going to help fill the stadium
a year after the pandemic and he will
sell a lot of jerseys create some
excitement and if it makes the cardinals
better it makes the cardinals better and
it makes me wonder what other moves
they're going to make you know sims and
i talked earlier today
about how much of a salesman kyler
murray can be to attract free agents who
get cut who don't get the offers that
they think they deserve
and they start looking for a team having
what with the cardinals
makes the cardinals more viable to
attract some of these free agents who
are going to be available
yeah there's no question about that mike
and and the cardinals do need to upgrade
at some positions and he can do that and
i think he will do that
you know that the top two since chandler
jones came into the league in 2012 he
has the most sacks in the nfl
and jj watt is second but i wonder from
jj
watt's standpoint how much having a guy
like jiddavion clowney when he was there
really helped him and he hasn't had him
the last couple years and you've seen
those sac numbers come down
so i'm going to be real curious to see
if it was the fact that he was getting
double teamed a whole bunch that led to
his
declining sac numbers over the last two
years and whether he will be helped by
chandler jones if chandra jones could
stay healthy
maybe j.j watts numbers go up because
they're going to be doubling chandler
jones so this could really be a great
pairing for the cardinals
and an improvement on their defense i
like hassan reddick and what he did
but i do agree with you that jj watt has
more leadership
and and really that is kind of the guy
they can look to on that defense to kind
of lift that defense up probably you're
right something
that they have needed patrick peterson
might have been that guy
before his play kind of declined i'm not
sure he's that guy now
the thing that makes me nervous more
than anything else is the injury history
because of the position he plays the
wear and tear
and i admire a player who understands
all the work
all the effort all the training it's all
put at risk every time he steps onto
that field
and it's not a matter of if but when
there's going to be another injury
that's going to cause
surgery rehab effort he had
i think it was a hernia
surgery core muscle injury in
philadelphia several years ago and i
think this was
one of peter king's columns about just
the despair
that you feel and at some point you ask
yourself why am i putting myself through
this but it shows you have a true love
of the game
and here he is hall of famer and now he
gets a chance to pursue a championship
with a team that is better
than the team that he was with although
that's a fairly low bar given where the
texans are right now speaking of the
texans
they play the cardinals this year in
arizona the packers
come to arizona the cardinals go to the
titans so he'll have that mike frable
reunion
he goes back to texas how about them
cowboys
hosting the cardinals this year and
based on peter king's explanation of how
they're going to do the 17th game
he'll get to go to cleveland a place
that was courting him
aggressively he'll be in cleveland after
all but for one night and one night only
when the cardinals come to town for that
17th game not that it'll be the last
game of the season but it's the extra
game this year
it will pit the cardinals against the
browns so uh if
if peter's report from today have no
reason to to doubt it but if that
17th game ends up pitting
third place team from the nfc west
against third place
team from the afc north so uh there'll
be some
intriguing games that have a little more
spice
you know the free agency and the draft
will give some of these games that we
know are already going to be on the
schedule more intrigue and so here are
four or five more games that have more
intrigue
with what picking the cardinals sharing
yeah i can't wait to see him play the
texans i only wish that game was in
houston mike i think that would be fun
to
to see deandre hopkins and j.j white go
back to houston black to settle for
houston coming to them and it will be a
different look for them playing against
the texans really strange
now jj watts decision to sign with the
cardinals
knocked russell wilson off the top of
the stack
but there was an intriguing development
as it relates to russell wilson
one of his four preferred destinations
one of the quarterbacks playing for one
of those four teams
and one of that quarterback's immediate
family members
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports